أرمينيا تنتقد ما
ورد عن اعتقال أذربيجان لأربعة من
القادة السابقين لناجورنو كاراباخ،
وتأتي هذه الاعتقالات الأخيرة بعد أسبوعين من
سيطرة باكو على
المنطقة الانفصالية في هجوم خاطف، وقد
فر معظم الأرمن العرقيين الذين يعيشون هناك والذين يبلغ عددهم 120 ألفًا إلى أرمينيا.  تاركين
وراءهم عاصمة شبه مهجورة
يصفها أحد قادة الأزمات في الصليب الأحمر بأنها
سريالية، وهناك تكهنات واسعة النطاق
بأن أذربيجان اعتمدت
بشكل كبير على الأسلحة الإسرائيلية لتصوير
الذهب الباريسي الهجومي معنا من
القدس، ما هي
العلاقة السابقة بين
إسرائيل وأذربيجان من حيث
الصفقات المسلحة ومدى أهمية
وأعتقد أن ما
نتحدث عنه هنا هو تكنولوجيا الطائرات بدون طيار
وأسلحة الطائرات بدون طيار، ما مدى أهمية الدور الذي
لعبوه،
نعم بيكي، لقد كانت
علاقة تحت الرادار نوعًا ما في
العام الماضي أو نحو ذلك  لقد أصبح أكثر
من مجرد رادار يتم الحديث
عنه علنًا، ولكن وفقًا لمعلومات من
معهد ستوكهولم الدولي لأبحاث السلام في الفترة من 2016 إلى 2020، فإن
حوالي 69 من واردات الأسلحة الرئيسية في باكو
جاءت مباشرة من إسرائيل 69 والتي
تشكل حوالي 17 بالمائة من صادرات الأسلحة الإسرائيلية
الآن معظمها  هذه هي تلك
الطائرات بدون طيار والصواريخ وقذائف الهاون والطائرات بدون طيار
التي سمعنا
عنها الكثير بالطبع في هذا الصراع الأخير، والآن
لماذا تعود هذه العلاقة
إلى الجغرافيا السياسية، تنظر إلى موقع
أذربيجان على الحدود الشمالية لإسرائيل
وستفهم لماذا
تريد إسرائيل ذلك  كونك قريبًا منهما يرى أن إيران
تمثل تهديدًا مباشرًا، وكانت هناك
بالفعل تقارير مختلفة تفيد بأن
المخابرات الإسرائيلية استخدمت بالفعل
أذربيجان كقاعدة لإجراء
عمليات في إيران وأن إسرائيل
تحصل أيضًا على نسبة لا بأس بها من
نفطها الخام من أذربيجان أيضًا.  ولكن في
السنوات الأخيرة هو في الواقع
العام الماضي، لذا أصبحت العلاقة في الواقع
أكثر علنية قليلاً، ففي شهر
مايو من هذا العام، قام الرئيس الإسرائيلي
إسحاق هرتزوغ بزيارة رسمية إلى
أذربيجان حيث استقبل
حرس الشرف وخلال تلك الرؤية
الأذربيجانية  لقد قال الرئيس إن
أذربيجان لديها إمكانية الوصول إلى
المعدات الإسرائيلية الحديثة في هذه المنطقة لسنوات عديدة
مما يساعدنا على تحديث
قدرتنا الدفاعية وأن نكون قادرين على
حماية دولتنا وقيمنا
ومصالحنا الوطنية وسلامتنا الإقليمية
ولكن الصراع الأخير  وقد
زاد التدقيق في
العلاقة، حيث كان هناك في الآونة الأخيرة
افتتاحية في صحيفة هيريتس الإسرائيلية ذات الميول اليسارية
حيث قالوا إن
بصمات إسرائيل موجودة في جميع أنحاء
التطهير العرقي في زاوية كاراباخ،
وقال السفير الأرمني في إسرائيل إن الأسلحة الإسرائيلية قال
هذا بالفعل في  في مقابلة أجريت مؤخرًا مع صحيفة
جيروزاليم بوست أن الأسلحة الإسرائيلية
تُستخدم ضد المدنيين في تلك
المنطقة، تواصلنا مع
وزارة الدفاع الإسرائيلية XUV للتعليق على هذا الأمر،
وبعد طلب متكرر
قالوا مرارًا وتكرارًا إنه
ليس لديهم تعليق على الوضع بشكل صحيح.  الآن
بيكي